alors moi bon moi je suis étonné voilà
j'en squatteurs mais moi je crois tu pas
les gens comme vous madame vous êtes une
biens privés et je trouve ça dégueulasse
que des gens se prennent vos
appartements ou vos biens pour lesquels
vous vous êtes battus toute votre vie ou
vos parents sont battus toute votre vie
peut avoir c'est bien là c'est pas
normal qu on squatte
les bâtiments que j'ouvre ce que sont
des grands bâtiments sont pas des
appartements et que j'assume sous mon
nom que ma responsabilité personnelle
parce que je suis poursuivi en justice
pour ce que je suis bien évidemment
ce sont des bâtiments qui appartiennent
au gouvernement qu'ils appartiennent à
l'état vous voyez il ya plus de 300
milles sans abri en france 600 abris
n'était pas à la rue il ne serait pas
chez vous si l'état faisait quelque
chose pour reloger ces gens ils ne
seraient pas obligés de squatter chez
vous
premièrement combien de bâtiments
vacants appartenant à l'état ou aux
gouvernements restent vides il ya en
2019 le 23 mai 2010 9 à strasbourg un
jeune de 23 ans s'est suicidé à 5 10
mètres de moi le 19 juillet 2019 j'ai
ouvert le plus grand bâtiment de l'est
un bâtiment de 2000 m² qu'un permis de
loger plus de 2000 personnes en deux ans
d'accord nous quand on ouvre un squat on
a souvent l'image des squats c'est
dégueulasse sa puce et des drogués c'est
des clochards c'était bon à rien et avec
des règles moins mais quoique pas
d'alcool pas de drogue pas de sexisme
pas de violence agents de sécurité ou
montrent une association il ya un projet
au monde des gens des petits projets
pour réinsérer donc c'est passé des
diplômes à des gens moi je n'ai jamais
été à l'école là j'ai décroché un
récemment un diplôme d'autant que
médiateur social l'accès au droit et
services d'accord on monte des
conventions on est là pour faire monter
des projets de terrain monsieur le
feutre on a vu ce qui se passe dans le
cas d'un appartement personnel mais
qu'est ce qui se passe vis-à-vis de la
justice dans votre cas dans quinze jours
soit dans un immeuble qui appartient à
l'état c'est ce qui se passe sur le plan
de la juste et l'état que tu parais que
madame l'état porte plainte c'est
d'actes mans la même chose d'accord
l'état porte plainte contre la personne
qui se revendique le squatteur là dans
mon cas c'est toujours moi et ensuite
une période de jugements de justice où
là c'était la mairie de strasbourg qui
avait porté plainte et heureusement pour
moi il y avait la municipale qui était
en cours donc les écolos bobos ils ont
ils ont ils ont tellement fait de
promesses bidons de trucs nanana que au
final nous sommes un peu endormis et on
a signé une convention avec eux la
plainte a été retirée d'accord mais
c'est ce qu'on peut faire aussi avec les
privés ou de madame aurait pu retirer sa
plainte il avait trouvé cité inca j'ai
lu vous aviez ouvert 300 squat ça se
règle sans toujours comme ça j'imagine
sommes pas tous malheureusement on a
beaucoup quand fermé il a quelques uns
quand et médiatisé dont l'hôtel de la
rue à strasbourg qui est devenu un
exemple aujourd'hui puisque strasbourg
capitale des droits de l'homme si une
convention temporaire avec un sans abri
comme moi c'est quand même pas mal quand
même pour comcom bonne étiquette qu'on
montre que c'est possible de s'en sortir
de la baisse de la rue avec des projets
et des envies et que aujourd'hui ici
comme je vous dis encore l'état paye 80
euros par jour par nuit dans des eaux
dans des eaux dans des hôtels pour loger
les sans-abri
servir moins cher que de ouvrir des
bâtiments vacants en fait le nécessaire
pour que les choses soient claires quand
il ya une convention ça veut dire que
c'est légal ils égalisent à l'hôtel de
la rue massey radio a été dga a été
légalisé après dix-huit mois de combats
et de jugement à l'époque où il s'est au
fil de ses pas plus d'égalité que ça
alors sont vraiment d'abord et bravo ce
que vous faites c'est une course
extraordinaire mais pourquoi
c'est pas plus d'égaliser parce que les
mairies ne font pas confiance à ceux qui
le vivent mal heureusement dont il y en
a 500 abris j'ai vécu huit ans dans la
rue ce qui m'a permis d'ouvrir plus de
trois son squat parce que si je
m'apprêtais à la rue j'aurais jamais
ouvert de squats
si nous faisait confiance à ceux qui le
vivent réellement est donnée de la
chance à ces gens-là de s'en sortir on
serait pas obligés de squatter les
privés moi sincèrement madame suis
sincèrement désolé pour votre bien et
s'ils pouvaient vous aider à les
retrouver un squat ailleurs qu
appartiennent à l'état pour que vous
puissiez retrouver votre bien mais je
vis figures prend une tournure
inattendue mais ça c'est très
intéressant franchement la proposition
figurez vous que vous venez de faire je
pense qu'elles préfèrent aller dans
votre choix de retourner chez elle
ouahmed squatter son butin j'ai pensé à
lui proposé d'aller squatter ailleurs le
problème c'est que cette personne ne
voulait pas à l'extérieur elle était
très bien dans le 9ème ne voulait pas
habiter en banlieue il faut savoir que
cette personne gagne 1800 euros par mois
elle à 1800 euros de revenus nets dont
des aides sociales mais elles ne
voulaient pas dépenser d'argent au loyer
s est une récidiviste elle a squatté un
appartement pendant deux ans avant
d'arriver dans le mien quand elle a été
expulsé de l'appartement précédent elle
est rentrée chez moi et cette personne
en cantal a été expulsé de chez moi
maintenant elle est effectivement logées
dans un hôtel à opéra ça fait donc cinq
ans qu'elle a pas payer de loyer et
qu'elle gagne 1800 euros par mois c'est
pas c'est pas du tout le même genre de
squatters